okay beautiful [ __ ] we are back okay
you're back I'd be reasonably and we are
dealing with laughs after we doing it
throw to the world okay so we're gonna
talk to this bench and I get a hug again
I years a long way to go Allah phone
already got [ __ ] okay I can't play a
lovegame I'll play a little game anyways
how you doing tonight betcha you doing
good I'm like outside I could [ __ ] up a
struggle yes yes oh yeah you see this
[ __ ] cootie through the shout because
we're supposed to for all I talking i'm
going to go bad they talk so wow she
makes a lot of what might stick out
donating proceeds sky where did you
learn a vet who have you been talking
the plagues of course they specialize in
the air yeah yeah now yeah I like a very
famous would you simply be no no but
heed my warning the blades may say they
said no which is called dragon around we
do not regret this loss dragon rentals
not only person acts the master of art
he is our leader he surpasses us all he
lives in sick he speaks to us only read
only those whose voice is strong can
find the path we will teach you a shout
to open the wait okay oh [ __ ] is again
tighter by the day
JS [ __ ] fast travel follow me I will
show you how to have fallen let's catch
up on the next sky above voice that God
is like it I hate we need to fall people
David [ __ ] sucks running man I play a
love game sucked it may be a second
settle does
right
they're a path that talk to father max
nice through this case I will show you
how to open the way
shall we bet
chef
I will grant you my understanding of
clear sky okay I'll let me figure
this is your final gift from us
dragonball lose it well each I can't pay
away
God will blow away the business today
Lockett arrogant but only for a time the
pasta Papa max is perilous yeah yeah
yeah
let's go Don what is happening here oh
yeah what's up [ __ ] is that
oh yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] add that
potion
Oh
back
what's up there so I can require like
really help to get over it
it is draining my stamina
alright
that's [ __ ] fast travel to
yeah a fast travel through this
what the [ __ ] Samuel Oh greetings
wounded the [ __ ] racket I am harz an
axe who are you what brings you to my
school ma my Mountain yes it has been
long since I have him back with a
stranger I gave in to the temptation to
Durham station not until introduction by
long tradition the elder speaks first
here my who wasn't feel it in your bones
match it
Oh Dovahkiin why do you improve here is
not what involved a catalyst word of
power a gift to Hakeem yo understand
fire as the douve to hypnotize yourself
y-you-you second fire breath or not yes
like the dragon blood runs strong in you
it is long since I had the pleasure of
speech with AH you would not come all
this way for King Bach with an old dov'è
know you seek your wet hmm but I do not
know the fune use your kind jaw our ha
dream a our minds them all in good time
I need a slap at the rally I'll do in
same but why why must you cruise her
some would say perhaps this world is
simply the egg of the next culpa lean
bulking hard they're all fools even we
who write those but you do you know why
I live here at them true but few now
remember her vaalu cansada yes and no
reach the Nords of those days use them
it was the careless the Elder Scroll
they used it is an artifact from outside
the Kellers Elder Scrolls as you name
but this is only a small not intent I
knew which is why I have lived here
there for thousands of more
years I have waited I knew where he
would emerge TD crunch if you brought
that hell with the Elder Scroll that was
used to break you could learn dragon
trend oh yeah rope tow thanks Rocco
forgot